so let's start with X what I'm going to
do is I'm going to get rid of X from
these equations by starting with this
one
because it has one X already by itself
okay so I'm going to rearrange equation
two I'm gonna make X the subject that's
how solving my substitution works and
that's a fairly straightforward seven by
the way you might wonder why I put
dashes through my Zed's that's because
when I'm riding in a hurry my ends look
an awful lot like twos and maybe yours
as well you don't need me to tell you
that's gonna be a bad thing to happen to
you if you're Miss reading your own
working okay not to mention for marking
this reads you're working all right
this is a new equation I've got it from
equation 2 so I'm going to call it to
where I could call it four but I'm gonna
have a lot of equations here and I've
got to be able to track where they come
from what shall I do it to a what's the
point of making text the subject okay if
X is the subject now I can substitute it
into stuff and I'm going to substitute
into two places this is equation two a
so tell me the place where I should not
substitute it don't put it back in here
you will get something true but useless
instead it's gonna have to go into these
two okay once you put that in there will
be no more X's in either of these
equations and you can solve them just
like a normal pair of linear equations
can you do that I'll give you a bit of a
head start on me substitute this into
equation one and equation three or three
and then see what you get from there off
you go
okay I saw a little bit I know some
people are still going just have a look
at what I have done okay because despite
how much this looks like this feels like
it's about algebraic manipulation
because that's the bulk of what you're
doing the really important thing is the
movements what is the path that you are
taking through this question where are
you going and do you know what turns
you're taking okay you can see just like
we discussed before I rearranged too so
I'm not going to put that back into
itself I put it back into one and three
and you can see because I've taken the
same basis I've said what I'm
substituting into what okay now I admit
you look at that and it doesn't look
promising at the moment okay
however we've got good reason to think
for a little while the numbers are
getting messy because these three things
they've got numbers everywhere things
are not gonna fall out straight away
when you look at that I've got a new
equation that I have labeled it
this is 3/8 what I want you to do is
look carefully at 1a and 3/8 you have
turned a problem which has three
equations and three variables I should
say three unknowns into a new kind of
problem what is this problem with 183 oh
this is just a pair of equations with a
pair of unknowns this is what we've
dealt with before in fact you can see by
my last line maybe my last line slightly
differs to you on can you see what
direction I'm headed in for this where
am I going
I want to yeah we're substitute this guy
back into here it looks like it's gonna
turn into a garbled bet mess but let's
see what happens sub 3 a into 1a okay
look there's one
like this okay have a look at it think
how would you like me to proceed in
terms of simplifying this think what's
the there are lots of ways to go through
this one might be the way to minimize
the errors that we can make suggestions
yeah I am going to multiply 3 by 7
because immediately that we get rid of
this fraction here otherwise I'm going
to be dealing with fractions all the way
through there's no reason why I can't do
that but I don't want to do that okay so
in a multiply through you can see while
you're at it I suppose if you multiply
through they'll get rid of the 7 you
might as well expand some seriously okay
so I think I've got my numbers here and
again like I said no shame in using your
calculator for these because I know
about you but I don't know my 13 times
tables very well okay so here I am and I
successfully turned three unknowns three
equations into two unknowns two
equations into one unknown one equation
which was you can see the progress okay
one of the things that I noticed when
students do these kinds of questions
because they do not learn where they are
going sometimes you are round and round
and round and never make any progress
through the question if you just focus
on what's actually happening not the
algebra not the manipulations focus
somewhere and putting things you can see
at every step I am progressing 170 taken
143 you can do that in your head
touching thing it's negative 73 and you
can confirm with your calculator that if
you do this subtraction key are you sure
you get negative 73 again that's a good
sign okay so now after all that work use
use that equals one
I'll admit it is slightly disappointing
like I did all that work and it's just
one but at least with a system like this
because we know it's messy we will do
what we can and I use a spreadsheet to
do this to make sure the numbers you get
at the end are nice and me that was all
the hard work now it's all downhill what
am I gonna do with Zed equals one
I'm gonna substitute it where's the most
common sense place to quit yeah if you
have a look I've got two choices really
I'm in here that's one eight or here
that's three eight before we choose one
why does it make sense to put into one
of these because they've really got two
variables right so then do one step back
okay
correct why don't one unknown now that
I've got said I'm going to suggest this
is probably a quicker way to go because
Y is already this subject I mean you'll
get the same answer out both ways but um
I'm just going to go straight here so
I'm going to sub Z into Michael at 3a
right right here so I'm gonna go y
equals 107 11 minus 25 11 minus 25 is 11
minus 25 is really sure it's negative 14
which is reassuring because again you
now have another integer value okay are
you happy with that okay wasp it I now
know is that I now know why lust unknown
where would you like me to put it yes
perfect okay because you can see save
yourself some work if you've already
made something the subject and that's
what you want to solve well you might as
well use that so let's sum both Y and
Zed
that equation that will make it easiest
first upon what do you think happy okay
now just to conclude well done you've
got through it
did you notice like I said at this point
I said it's all downhill right it's all
high when you're still dealing with
multiple variables but as you I'm sorry
multiple unknowns but as you peel them
off it becomes simpler and simpler and
simpler so if you can get to this first
major hurdle on everything spitefully
just to complete if you want you can say
at the bottom of x equals this why was
this daddy who's that that's one of your
options some said that as a marker I
don't have to dig through your twenty
lines of working to find your solutions
so if you say that that that it's
completely unambiguous alternatively
something I see frequently and I also
give it thumbs up is if you arrive here
in x equals four
you put a circle around that a circle
around that and a circle around that so
that I as the market can quickly
identify yep you found the right values
and I can verify that we go okay does
anyone have any questions now
just one more thing before I situations
on these simultaneous equations okay the
key the key is all about these movements
it's not actually about the mechanics
this is what's important
when students have trouble is I used to
remember in my first year teaching I saw
a student and he spent three pages three
full pages like this because he was just
going in circles and never actually
successfully eliminating out any of
these variables right and you can go
round and round and round and pour hours
into a question like this and waste your
time that's why the important be is do
you know where you're going and why
you're substituting this into this